お風呂あれです肇社長です it だけでちょうど2週間前くらいかな
[音楽]
僕は動画で
宣言していました遊戯王の世界退散
もう俺ちょっと本当に緊張がほぐれても
を揺るぎませんで昨日は今日は緩み切ってくれ遊戯王カードの世界大会予選 wcs
20108の予選が始まって僕はに瞬間前の動画ならず4戦を勝つと
一時がします2月中もまたまた大会があるんだよもうちょっと頑張ってきます次こそ
だぞ
もっと
入ってませんでしたね2月18日縁
予選大会
優勝してきましたーー
ああああああ
優勝賞品ですプレイマットハイアー
終わったぁー
を1
いやーこっからなんですけどこっからなんですよ5月6月でに告げる県の代表を決める
大会があるんで
部活で県大会ですね県大会があるのでそれに向けて頑張んなきゃいけないんですけども
ひとまず12ヶ月ぐらいは僕はも大会に出る必要がないって本当によがったよ何より
もうさなんかどーで行っちゃったからプレッシャー襲ったんですよね去年優勝したから
今年もいい
移送しないとまずはお前なんかまぐれで買った山みたいになるんで2年連続で来たんだ
よ
とそれ以上言わないでも来いと言う家でぶつかってましたちょっと見まず友情の大会の
追及を受けがどんな漢字がわからない遠いともちょっと見てみましょう
どうぞやっぱりというわけでこんな感じですねもう何だろうな
あの消して一緒にしてるわけじゃないんですけどもう囲碁と将棋の大会みたいな雰囲気
がすぐ続いております
これずっとですね相手の方が考えてますねスカイピースの仁丹みたいな人でした
執政マジでねもうねそれでも超擬態語ですよどんだけ先呼んで宴会を考えるかどうか何
を出してどうなるかをずっと考えなきゃいけないんでめちゃくちゃ当たっ使うんですよ
ねというか悩んでますね
獅子俺もこれね普通の像してるんですけど心の中だと
夢
同社何もできねぇで思ってるをするんですけどそこをポーカーフェイスでこのあって
いるはテクニックの一つです
この相手がズってくれるで考えてますねなんかメモとりましたヒントになるようなこと
は全部メモしてます僕は
くれたかちゃんで勝ちら通すか俺のポーカーフェイスこれで
超悩んでくださいね速めますよ本当になります決勝戦まできた時点でもすごいことだし
行ってで負けたりするんで本当に慎重に選ばないとダメなんですよ
2の顔してますけど下手足学科額に震えててもうてとか冷え切ってますからねえっ夫肘
をついていくこの間にも2人のものすごいこの思考の
判断とかどうすればどうなるんだどうしてどうしてどうならどんなになっていうのも
いろんなね
goot 今考えております
多分ねーさあ相手が入って打ちましたもうスター創刊しただけでも
このピルツ空気です相手がモンスター召喚して効果を発動するんですけど
その効果に対して僕3つぐらいできることがあってその3つに取れなければいいの
かっていうのは一生懸命考えていますこの顔でもう頭が刃付けてそうですねえっにょを
書いてみますが何も変わらないカードと海王してますね決まってるんです本当にねうん
頭使うんやでちゃんとねカードを見ても効果を入念に確認してちゃんとやっていかない
と
ミスするしっかり見ていきますか会える考える外れ
トラップカードを使ってそれにチェーンしてもうその他を発動しましたこれにた試合
ってぬ振りますが通って行く
さあアティヤどうぞ
てくるか
[音楽]
東さん
てるん
考えたすべて物優勝できた感じでございますよがだもうねほんとあのなかなか動画とか
で言ってるんですけど結構練習しまくってましたね
輸入カードって対処の手札が5枚から始まるわけなんですけど
を行い弱いかどうかけど負けることもあると思うんですけど結局何する
してもカードゲームでしてもスポーツにしても勉強にしても何事に岩質んでもいること
なんですけども
うんって大事なことなんですよってが運の要素ってすごい大事運がいいだけで勝つこと
もあるし
合格することもあるし浮気こともあるし池ビルがよくてもちゃんと電車してたり
ドライブしてないとうまくいかない時もあるんです
なんで僕今回そんな多少の運もあったと思うんですけど
運だけで勝ったと思って
ないですそれぞれにいろんなことを研究したり勉強したりして実践をしまったって何と
か手につかんだ
階級章園大会の出場権利を得たのではないかなと思います
事故った運転どんなことにも絡んでいきますのでわずかなうんとたくさんの努力家
いい結果が出たのではないかなと思っておりますいやほんとねー
ずっとずっとそわそわしてたんですよあとはもう決勝大会と思って行ってくれますから
ねマジでとりあえず僕の遊戯王の春は終わりましたまた店舗代表戦が3月4月まで4戦
が続くんですけどホワイトが友だちのお手伝いをしながら静岡県代表の大会に立って
頑張ってきたんだから僕使ったができるんですけどもあのでサブテラー目指してビート
でこうやってどうしなかっ
ていくいわゆるインキャビートで出来るんですけどちょっと天蓋を見ていきましょう
どうぞ
入ったわけで書店がこんな感じだとどういう国になるかやってみましょうまずは
とりあえずチャンバーの発動します新しくとかこれでおっきくなっています
[音楽]
ブーバー連戦投稿破壊されなくなった
次のドローフェイズに saint できると友人が出来上がります
同大ん
me
あっはぁ